متخيل يا عمو انت يعني لو كانت عندك بنات
زيي هيك قبك كنت بالليل هيك تسيبهم يبردوا
يضلهم مع الجوع طول الليل يعيطوا ولما
يجوعوا ايش يعملوا يحطوا الحرام عليهم
عشان امهم ما تتوجع عشانهم يعني انا
بالليل بكون جوعانه بالليل ايش عشان ما
يطلع صوت الجوع عنده في بطني بطني بضل
يكرك بالليل بحط الحرام عن ت امي عشان
ماما ما تسمعش انه جوعان عشان ماما ما
تتوجع علي بس برضه الحمد لله في غيرنا مش
حاسس في النعم اللي حسين فيها يعني احنا
ايش ذبنا هيك يصير فينا تشوف اطفال العالم
الثانيه كيف في تركيا وفي اليابان وفي
الصين وفي امريكا وفي اوروبا كيف عايشين
عايشين احسن من عيشتنا على قلي ابوهم امهم
جنبيهم اخواتهم جنبيهم اغراضهم جنبيهم
كتبهم مدرستهم شنطهم كل شي جنبيهم كل شي
يعني ما بقولو يعني بلاوا الشي قبل ما
يقولوا بدهم
اياه
m